do you think their confidence is shaken
at this point no not shaking
but stirred I was gonna get it not
shaking but stirred meaning it's stirred
up like you're like okay wait a minute
the things that we were doing pretty
easily we're not doing easily anymore
and why not so now you have to question
why not when they won one game you're
like they're the Boston Celtics they
were the number two seed in the in the
in the NBA of course they're going to
win games possibly but when you lose two
in a row you're stirring it up and like
now you have to question and your
strategy has to change
you'll lose two in a row you'll lose
Gabe Vincent for this game yeah I don't
know what his status is for game six
I think
why they are confidence is shaking they
can't beat the seven if the Celtics play
well
I mean
you know there's a reason everybody
picked the Celtics now the thing that's
disappointed about the Celtics
you should not be up and down this late
in the season in the Eastern Conference
Finals but we saw it against Atlanta
uh we saw it against uh who they played
in second round Milwaukee Milwaukee no
no that's Miami I got you yeah no that's
Miami but they were against Philadelphia
but and they did the same thing in game
one game two and game three but if they
play like they do in game four and five
Miami can't beat them they're not good
enough I think you know Miami's still
saying okay we know what we have to do
this this right now forces them to focus
you know you would think after the last
loss they'll be a little bit more
focused this right here forces them to
focus and it's gonna be a great game
it's gonna be a great game I cannot wait
till Saturday they uh they will try to
join only three other teams
um enforcing a game seven if they can
win game six in how much money
but nobody's ever done it nobody's ever
won the best of seven went down three
nothing that was that that was a well I
cannot happen I can't kidding what I
gave the book it gave me and Kenny was
getting excited for a sec I thought they
were gonna get into eight
you go back to game four of this series
early third quarter Heat by nine and
then comes the Boston 18-nothing run and
they have dominated since that run
um
so what does that tell you about what we
can expect to see on on Saturday in uh
in Miami you know Jimmy said same thing
Chuck said about Boston Furniture games
we're not hitting the shots we're not
playing defense he is correct they have
to play better they have to play more
energy Celtics did what they were
supposed to do they know they're better
to him team the first two games are
terrible they played hard
on game three and game four so
you know for me it's it's going to be a
battle of Wheels you know Chuck Chuck
Chuck thinks it's a muscle win for Miami
I kind of agree with him but you know
they just have to play better they have
to play it harder I disagree what they
said about bam
bam can't allow that to happen I don't
care about the defense you know coming
in like if the defense is coming in on
them my Shooters are open you got to get
the ball and you got to make the correct
play and when you get the one-on-one
coverage from a guard I don't care if
they're the same size or not you can't
let a guard play you you can't let Jason
Tatum play you can't let Grant Williams
play you he has to be better and again
when he gets 20 or more the Heat win so
you know all that stuff about you know
they're packing the paint you want him
to pack the paint so you can kick it out
to your Shooters the Saving Grace for
Miami is the fact that while they've
been dominated the last six quarters of
the series they do have game six in
their gym with a chance to win the
series yeah that don't mean anything as
you knew because what do you mean it
doesn't mean anything because Miami won
twice here so yeah but you still have
that game six in your place it's about
how you play the home court is great but
you got to play
and
I can't believe uh listen everybody
knows the Boston Celtics the best team
don't always win assist because even
though you have a better team you have
to play better
the Miami Heat played better the first
three games
the Boston Celtics played the best the
last two games
if the if these two teams play their
best the Celtics are going to win they
have to have we said it going back to
game one
Miami gonna drive the same speed limit
every time
but
these Celtics right now they're driving
a faster speed limit and if they make
shots and play good defense they're
going to win not game six and game seven
but
it's they might have waited too late
because you're right Miami no this game
seven is game seven is game six so
you're saying that Miami
shots you still got Boston I think if I
know I said both teams play their best
the Celtics are a better team no but let
me ask the question you know you're
talking about Boston making shots if
Miami make their threes you still got
Boston no because you because what
happens is for some reason they both
don't play defense they get
psychologically down when they're not
making shots even Jimmy Butler that's
exactly right but but Ernie that's
normal nobody goes to a game and says
let me just play defense I mean when you
are making shots and things are going
good yeah you give a crazy energy on the
defensive you mean you never had that
mindset Chuck when you went to a game
I'm gonna go here and play defense
nobody ever says that you know nobody
ever said let me go out here and play
defense hey uh be our watch to earn by
the way